CHANCE VISITED THE RUINS OF A
SMALL TOWN OUTSIDE KYIV STILL
REELING FROM THE CARNAGE
INFLICTED BY RUSSIA.
>> IN THE LIBERATED VILLAGES
NORTH OF THE UKRAINIAN CAPITAL,
THE STREETS ARE LINED WITH THE
SCARS OF WAR.
AND IT'S NOT JUST BUILDINGS
DESTROYED.
WE MET SERGEI, A VILLAGER WHOSE
HOME WAS OVERRUN BY RUSSIAN
TROOPS.
WHO THEN SHOT HIM, HE SAYS, AND
LEFT HIM FOR DEAD.
HE SHOWS ME THE GUT-WRENCHING
BULLET WOUNDS, BUT HIS EMOTIONAL
SCARS RUN EVEN DEEPER.
SOMETIMES, I HAVE NIGHTMARES AND
CAN'T SLEEP AT NIGHT, AND I PRAY
THEY WON'T EVER COME BACK, HE
TELLS ME.
THROUGH TEARS OF PAIN AND ANGER.
I'LL NEVER FORGIVE RUSSIANS FOR
WHAT THEY DID, HE SAYS.
AND THEY DID MUCH WORSE.
JUST STEPS FROM SERGEI'S DOOR,
POLICE FORENSIC TEAMS ARE
UNEARTHING YET ANOTHER CRIME
SCENE.
WEEKS AFTER RUSSIAN TROOPS WERE
PUSHED FROM THIS AREA, LOCALS
ARE STILL FINDING THE BODIES OF
THEIR NEIGHBORS.
WE WERE SHOWN THREE MAKESHIFT
GRAVES ON THIS STREET ALONE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WHEN YOU SEE
THIS?
WHAT GOES THROUGH YOUR MIND WHEN
YOU SEE THESE BODIES BEING DUG
FROM THESE SHALLOW GRAVES AT THE
SIDE OF THE ROAD?
>> SO WE SEE THE RUSSIAN TROOPS
HAVE ALREADY GONE FOR MORE THAN
ONE MONTH.
BUT WE STILL FIND THE EVIDENCE
OF THEIR PRESENCE.
>> THAT'S ASTONISHING, ISN'T IT,
EVEN A MONTH AFTER THEY HAVE
GONE, MORE THAN A MONTH, STILL
FINDING BODIES.
>> UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS TELL ME
MORE THAN 320 CIVILIANS ARE
STILL MISSING IN THIS REGION
ALONE.
ONE BY ONE, THEY'RE BEING FOUND.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE MISSING.
YOU CANNOT IMAGINE THE EYES OF
MOTHERS WHOSE CHILDREN ARE LOST.
YOU CANNOT IMAGINE EYES OF
RELATIVES WHOSE BELOVED HAVE
BEEN CAPTURED OR HAVE BEEN
KILLED ON THE FRONT LINE.
>> IT IS AN AWFUL, GRIM
BUSINESS, DIGGING UP BODIES OF
THE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
SCATTERED ACROSS THIS ENTIRE
COUNTRY, IN SHALLOW GRAVES THAT
HAVE YET TO BE IDENTIFIED.
THIS WAS VITALE, JUST 43 YEARS
OLD, AND THE NEIGHBORS TELL ME
HE DIDN'T PRESENT A THREAT TO
THE RUSSIANS.
HE WASN'T A SOLDIER.
IN FACT, HE WAS VULNERABLE.
HE DIDN'T HAVE A JOB.
HE DRANK TOO MUCH.
HIS FAMILY HAD LEFT HIM.
BUT HE WAS HUNGRY.
AND HE WAS TRYING TO GET SOME
FOOD FROM A RUSSIAN VEHICLE THAT
WAS PARKED JUST HERE WHEN THEY
CAUGHT HIM.
AND SHOT HIM DEAD.
JUST ONE OF THE MANY ALLEGED
CRIMES, MANY TRAGEDIES IN THE
UKRAINIAN NIGHTMARE THAT'S YET
TO END.
>> JAKE, TONIGHT, THERE ARE MORE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PLIGHT OF THE
CIVILIAN POPULATION,
PARTICULARLY IN AREAS WHERE
THERE IS FEROCIOUS FIGHTING
STILL TAKING PLACE BETWEEN THE
UKRAINIAN AND RUSSIAN FORCES.
MUCH OF THAT NOW CONCENTRATED IN
THE NORTHEAST OF THE COUNTRY, IN
AND AROUND THE CITY OF
SEVERODONETSK WHERE WE NOW KNOW
FROM THE UKRAINIAN SIDE THAT 80%
OF THE CITY HAS FALLEN INTO
RUSSIAN HANDS.
AND THERE ARE SOCIAL MEDIA
IMAGES OF BODIES IN THE CENTER
OF THE CIT